le 21 novembre 2020 la cour d'assises
condamné johnatan d'aval à 25 ans de
réclusion criminelle pour le meurtre de
sa compagne johnatan d'aval a été
condamnée par cinq ans de réclusion
criminelle 25 ans de prison pour
johnatan d'aval une affaire aux
multiples rebondissements qui passionne
les conseils qui inspirait séries
téléfilms et nombreuses productions en
tous genres d'aval la série pourtant si
dans de telles histoires les proches des
victimes ce mur souvent dans le silence
ici les parents d'alexia d'avalon décidé
d'être sur le devant de la scène
s'énerve c'est pour montrer un vraiment
qui on est alors qu'il vient de sortir
un livre en hommage à leurs filles il
viendrait de vendre les droits
d'adaptation production gaumont pour en
faire une série en six épisodes il ya
aussi des gens qui vous en veulent des
gens qui vous reprochent d'en faire trop
une instrumentalisation récurrentes
comme l'a confié la mère de johnattan
dans l'est républicain je n'attaque
n'est pas d'accord avec ce film il a été
jugé qu'on le laisse en paix mon fils
n'est pas une bête de foire
l'association osez le féminisme s'est
aussi indigné d'un tel projet alors
livrés séries inspirées par la peur
d'aval comprenez vous la colère des
proches de john à thann
alors ça c'est un sujet qui fait
énormément on réagir sur les réseaux
aujourd'hui merci m eur choir dorfer
d'être avec nous remerciant là c'est un
bonheur nous avoir là dans la foi mais
on avait passé un vrai bon moment avec
vous et c'est vrai que on s'est tous
demandé quand on a vu cette news on
s'est dit s contre qui vont trop loin
est ce que vous comprenez la colère des
proches de jonathan non non non non ici
bien oui chez matthieu delormeau ou pour
ces quads sur un projet de série en
avant tant qu'avocate jonathan d'aval
d'abord ce projet de série il ne me
surprend pas il est il est connu depuis
un certain temps
deuxièmement j'ai toujours pensé y
compris pendant la sphère d'aval que non
seulement il y aurait des livres sur la
sphère dajjal et qu' il y aurait des
adaptations cinématographiques ou une
série qui qui est que qui naîtrait de
cette affaire-là il y en a déjà une je
le rappelle la série qui est passé sur
bfm en en quatre épisodes et il n'y a
aucune surprise pour moi si vous voulez
toutes les affaires pénales
extraordinaire ou hors normes ont fait
l'objet d'adaptations et je permets
simplement de préciser c'est pas une
question de choix parce que le principal
intéressé aujourd'hui johnatan d'aval
les parents d'alexia y compris les
parents de johnatan n'ont pas leur mot à
dire en réalité quand bien même comme on
achèterait pas su roi du livre des
parents d'alexia caumont tout à fait le
droit de faire un film l affaire est
dans le domaine public mais
juridiquement ont peu passionné m ça
amène quand même une certaine
crédibilité ça amène un plus quand même
qu'oddo beaumont et l'aval de la famille
et les droits du livre de la famille
c'est quand même un certain plus on va
pas se mentir bien sûr voilà c'est
évidemment un plus pour la série 1 /
après je ne sais pas quelles sont leurs
accords quelles sont leurs acteurs
mentaires de consulting c'est évident
que c'est un plus pour crédibiliser la
série c'est une évidence après on sait
aussi très bien et il ya des
négociations qui qui vont intervenir
entre les différentes maisons d'édition
parce que vous savez très bien que les
versions sont très opposées que nous ne
disons pas que nous avons la vérité dans
cette affaire mais la famille d'alexia
n'a pas non plus la vérité est que au
milieu de tout ça il ya une synthèse à
faire pour arriver à faire un sujet qui
soit beaucoup plus honnête et sincère
alors livré aux spectateurs la maman de
jonathan d'aval a réagi oui elle a dit
je ne suis pas d'accord avec cette
histoire de film et jonathan n'est pas
d'accord non plus mon fils n'est pas une
bête de foire j'en attends été jugé il
va faire sa peine qu'on le laisse en
paix si honteux c'est indécent mathieu
normand vous êtes d'accord avec la maman
dion et en aval alors évidemment c'est
c'est très difficile de juger sur ce qui
est arrivé aux parents de jonathan
navale de aux parents pardon de l'exia
cesi c'est horrible maintenant oui c'est
vrai qu'il a fallu attendre je crois à
30 ans à peu près pour que ce soit
adapté la sphère du petit grégory tout
ça et encore une fois personne ne sont
que le symbole là de vendre entre
guillemets même si ça aurait pu être
fait dans le domaine public devant notre
guillemets les droits de sa fille pour
une histoire où forcément on va remuer
un peu tout ça donc il ya beaucoup de
choses qui vont sortir danser dans cette
série des choses désagréables sur
jonathan peut-être des choses agréables
sur leur fille on va remuer un peu tout
tout tout se fonde je trouve que oui
symboliquement vendre touché de l'argent
sur la mort de son enfant symboliquement
ça me dérange énormément alors qu'il
valait réunion matthieu ballet
symboliquement tu peux tu peux rien dire
toi moi je peux rien dire à personne ici
ne veut rien dire tu n'as pas perdu un
enfant à partir du moment où moi je ne
peux pas porter un jugement de valeur
sur une famille qui a perdu une fille et
peu importe comment eux décide de gérer
leur deuil alors il y en a qui vont se
être reclus qui voudront voir personne
et parler à personne et d'autres qui
auront besoin d'écrire des livres que
des artistes s'emparent de l'histoire
pour en faire une chanson
d'autres à faire un film peu et parce
qu'ils ont besoin peut-être eu de la
faire vivre à travers une oeuvre
artistique un livre ou autre donc moi je
ne me permettrais jamais parce que je
n'ai pas connu cette douleur et je ne
souhaite à aucun d'entre nous n'est
jamais vide cette douleur symboliquement
gagner de l'argent avec la mort c'est le
sont en france
m l'association te mettre en tête quand
elle dit qu'on présente on va présenter
son fils comme une bête de foire où ça
vous ça vous évoque quoi alors écoutez
d'abord je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec avec votre analyse parce que
valérie pas oublier que les parents
d'élections perdues une ovation sûr on
peut ne pas être d'accord avec la façon
de l'exprimer on peut chacun avoir son
petit jugement mais vous avez raison moi
je n'ai pas perdu d'enfants journée je
ne le souhaite pas je ne le souhaite à
personne et leurs souffrances et les
réelles moi je les ai vécus sont des
gens qui m'ont touché je dis aussi que
martine laval est une femme très digne
je comprends son créatures au travers de
la presse en disant arrêtez on aimerait
qu'on arrête d'en parler on aimerait
qu'on passe à autre chose mais
malheureusement ce ne sera pas la
réalité alors je comprends tout à fait
la démarche de martine que je connais
bien pour que j'ai beaucoup de respect
je comprends aussi la démarche des
parents qui ne m'apprécie pas parce que
j'ai été leur adversaire à chercher été
l'avocat de johnatan et c'est dans
l'ordre des choses mais je m'interdis
tout jugement vis-à-vis de ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire notamment la
cession du droit du film et puis d'abord
vous avez raison qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire de cet argent ils n'en n'ont pas
besoin moi je n'aime pas beaucoup les
gens qui racontent leur vie et qu'ils
disent ce qu'ils font de leur argent je
ne suis pas inquiet sur ça je suis pas
persuadé qu'on soit dans une logique de
faire de l'argent sur le dos de alexia
mais je pense aussi que la résilience et
je pense aussi que pour des victimes
parce que ce sont des victimes tous les
chemins ne sont pas les même si vous
voulez pour arriver à faire leur deuil
alors moi je pensais qu'après le procès
j'avais écouté isabelle fouillot elle
avait dit maintenant on va pouvoir
tourner la page faire notre deuil c'est
peut-être plus compliqué c'est plus
compliqué parce que c'est pas une
affaire criminelle ordinaire pas sûr
parce que c'est une affaire qui
appartient à tous les français parce que
tout le monde a son petit avis sur la
sphère j'ai encore des gens qui
m'interpelle en me disant m vous savez
on dit sûr qu'il y avait un complice et
même parfois certaines disent c'est
peut-être pas de johnatan vous le savez
vous devez avoir des informations coûté
non c'est bien de johnatan non il y
avait pas de complice oui à une jeune
femme qui est mort dans des conditions
dramatiques
oui johnattan a beaucoup de regrets de
remords par rapport à ce qu'il a fait
mais il l'a fait il doit vivre avec
c'est sa peine en réalité complètement
de prison à peine 20 ans au delà de sa
peine de prison je peux vous assurer que
vivre avec ça les images elle reste le
déplacement du corps ça reste la
crémation ça reste c'est quelqu'un qui a
des remords qui a une conscience et
quand vous avez une conscience et vous
avez fait ça eh bien il faut vivre avec
avec ces nouvelles menaces et dure chez
les nouvelles par l'intermédiaire de
martin elle sent que c'est différent
c'est très difficile actuellement parce
qu'on reparle beaucoup de la faire mais
c'est dans l'ordre des choses c'est à
dire que vous savez on reproche aux
parents d'alexia les médias pourrait me
le reprocher à moi on pourrait reprocher
aux procureurs et publics du pic on
pourrait reprocher aux gendarmes qui se
sont exprimés dans
faites entrer l'accusé en réalité
j'avais traité tout le monde
d'hypocrites procès tout le monde à
participer à la chose médiate a fait
tout le monde alors maintenant venir
dire non mais vous savez les médias on
est obligé non alors c'est le seul point
de désaccord que j'ai avec la famille
fouillot je pense que ils sont d'accord
pour participer à ça et je pense que ça
choque il ya un moment faut faut passer
le petit cap de la petite doxa morale
qu'on s'impose pourquoi des parents de
victimes n'auraient pas le droit de
venir exprimer ce qu'ils ont ressenti
pourquoi des parents de victimes n'ont
pas droit de faire un livre pourquoi ils
n'ont pas le droit de participer à une
série je vois pas après je comprends
tout à fait martin parce que c'est une
maman qui parle et vous savez être la
mère d'une enfant qui a été tué c'est
terriblement difficile je ne sais pas ce
que c'est mais être la mère d'un homme
qui a tué c'est aussi horriblement
difficile alors justement randall
thunder forme et vous avez écrit un
livre extraits des rixes libère je
voulais qu'elle souhaite c'est la sphère
d'aval sous l'angle amoureux vraiment
sûr langue de l'amour c'est s'inscrire
comme ce qu'il sait mais profondément
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter parce que c'est vrai que c'est
passionnant je sais que les
téléspectateurs dans se passionne pour
cette affaire et c'est vraiment là vous
avez pris la faire
vraiment dans un cadre décortique et
ramassions sur le drame amoureux voilà
et c'est vrai que c'est moi j'adorais ce
que pour y raconter nos téléspectateurs
sans dévoiler bien sûr oui mais vous
savez c'est réellement passé voilà
alexia johnattan c'est un premier amour
elle n'a jamais connu personne il n'a
jamais connu et sonne et ce premier
amour très peu de premier amour subsiste
est bien celui ci va subsister et
jusqu'à une certaine période pendant
très longtemps l'entente est parfaite et
ce couple s'adorent et puis il y a un an
qui vont être très difficiles c'est la
dernière année alexis a beaucoup changé
on parle aussi des problèmes d'anorexie
qu'elle a pourquoi la changer parce que
elle a beaucoup évolué elle a fait des
études
johnattan et a toujours le même emploi
et puis parce qu'ils ont acheté une
maison et puis parce qu'elle aimerait
lorsque ce sont ses rêves maintenant
deux femmes un enfant que peut-être que
pour le jeune athènes c'est très
compliqué d'avoir un enfant et donc ils
ne sont plus en adéquation si vous
voulez la symbiose assez c est à partir
de ce moment là le couple va se déchirer
alexia va reprocher quoi johnattan de ne
pas l'aimer comme elle aimerait qu'il
aime et de johnatan va lui reprocher de
ne pas l'aimer comme il aimerait qu'elle
aime et donc ils ne se comprennent plus
et ils n'ont pas les mots et ils n'ont
pas l'expérience et je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas non plus l'éducation
sentimentale qui va avec et là où ce
couple aurait dû 10 périence en fait
même si l'expérience est là où ce couple
aurait dû dire on arrête on passe à
autre chose ils étaient prisonniers de
leur propre histoire d'amour et il ne
pouvait pas l'accepter et on le voit
dans un message d'alexia qui est
terrible qu'elle envoie une de ses
meilleures amies en lui disant tu vois
je souffre toujours ça va un peu mieux
je ne pleure plus mais je l'aimais je
reste
et là on aurait simplement pu lui dire
mais voyez je pense que les parents
d'alexia s'en veulent aussi de pas avoir
vu ça ça va pas il faut qu'on parle il
faut peut-être penser à faire autre
chose il faut peut-être vous séparer et
je pense que martin sont venues elles
aussi terriblement parce qu'il a envoyé
deux choses l essayer d'en parler à
johnattan et johnatan refusé de dire que
ça n'allait pas parce que ce couple est
aussi prisonnier de cette image mais
c'est cette image de barbie et ken
bonheur parfait qu'on leur a imposé
quelque part et qu'ils se sont imposés
et quand ce bonheur est devenu une
prison à un moment
personne ne voyez ce qui se passait dans
les murs roses de la maison mais vous
dire que l'ambiance était glaciale et
que sur les trois derniers mois
l'ambiance était psychologiquement même
violente parfois et que effectivement ce
jour du 28 octobre qu'est ce qui a fait
basculer ça a dérapé je voulais qu'elle
se taise c'est le pendant le titre du
livre c'est le pendant de cette impasse
que john est elle met en avant dix ans
elle m'a reproché mes défaillances elle
m'a dit un autre mais tu n'es pas un
homme et et il a dit je je les frappe et
puis je voulais qu'elle se taise et la
juge d'instruction le regarde et lui lit
mais pourquoi l'avez vous étrangler pour
pourquoi avez vous été jusqu'au bout et
là on a senti des mois et des mois de
frustration et de rancoeur où il a dit
je vous je voulais qu'elle se taise et
on a tout compris à ce moment là c'est à
dire que ces deux phrases combiné
synthétise parfaitement ce drame dont on
a énormément parlé qui est en réalité
une affaire criminelle je le dis j'ose
le dire qu'on ne se méprenne pas sur les
termes ordinaire pas extraordinaire et
qui est devenu pourtant une affaire
criminelle hors norme d'un point de vue
médiatique alors que je vous le dis nous
on ne l'avait pas vu venir au cabinet on
était persuadé qu'au bout de 48 heures
on ne parlerait plus de cette affaire
nous avons des affaires criminelles
d'une dimension bien plus importantes à
gérer est actuellement qui sont en cours
dont on parle très peu et cette affaire
est devenue la sphère des français des
mensonges de johnatan selon et élément
saillant aux français la marche blanche
à la marche blanche des français alex
est devenu ma fille des français et donc
je comprends toutes les passions qui
anime autour de ce débat mais je sais
aussi que derrière il ya un homme et une
femme monsieur henri madame henri des
pieds parole de johnatan et le beau père
de johnny tu attends je connais leurs
souffrances je leur parle je les connais
ces gens quand ils appellent ils sont
son mari voilà ces deux couples qui
souffrent énormément de toute cette
situation chacun à sa façon et et chacun
dans son genre c'est à dire marquer mais
très discrète la salle à m'avoir maman
de jonathan de natal et le papa et ils
vivent comment aujourd'hui
ex harris il est bien
il y va avec beaucoup de souffrance mais
beaucoup de dignité c'est très retenue
jamais ils n'en parlent jamais je n'ai
jamais entendu markin se plaindre de ça
il ya le regard des autres aussi oui
mais vous savez martine elle a toujours
wave mais martin
est là un certain niveau elle elle n'est
pas touché par le regard des autres un
peu ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
je vous regardez dans dans le couloir ce
que les autres en pensent eux je m'en
tape mais martin l instant comme ça nos
marques de jeux ps3 comment marier mais
mais mais mais martin c'est pas son
problème le regard des autres est
d'ailleurs dans sa façon d'être on le
voit très elle se dit les parents de
jonathan navale ce qu'il se dit d'un
moment vous l'avez évoqué il ya un
instant ce qui se dit on aurait
peut-être pu éviter ce drame si on avait
été plus à l'écouté pense que les deux
familles se dresser sa récente chez les
hommes c'est ça qu'on veut dire en fait
je pense que les deux familles s'en
veulent parce qu alexis à son destin
s'était pas de terminer dans un bain
dans ce bois des moulins et le destin de
johnatan s'était pas de finir dans un
centre de détention pour avoir tué sa
femme et je pense qu'il aurait fallu
deux mots mais que là où il ya plus de
mots et ben en général ce sont les coups
ce sont les violences et que ce qui est
triste et ce qui choque peut être aussi
c'est que vraiment ça n'aurait pas dû se
passer dans cette maison là mais ouais
c'est ça bonjour c'est la plus grosse
affaire oui voyez monsieur noyage jeu
il ya beaucoup de pédagogie à tirer de
ces affaires criminelles on en parle
dans le livre parce que en réalité et
c'est pour ça que je me pose beaucoup
aux associations féministes oit marlène
schiappa même qu'aux fins et autres
pourquoi parce que et ils ne parlent que
des conséquences il ne parle pas des
causes moi je suis persuadé que on
s'éduque qu'on éduque les jeunes enfants
les adolescents à des associations qui
essaie d'éduquer aussi qu'ils essayent
d'éviter le drame c'est un sénat devrait
être une priorité gouvernementale les
associations fait mieux que de nouveaux
avoirs aussi oui mais mais ça devrait
être plus que des associations ça
devrait être intégré donc dans
l'instruction l'éducation nationale
parce qu'on se rend compte que beaucoup
de parents sont défaillants parce qu'on
se rend compte que beaucoup d'enfants
d'adolescents en réalité ne sont pas
éduqués et que effectivement ils se
mettent en couple comme on va acheter un
livre dans un magasin ils se défont com
comme on jette une boîte de conserve à
la poubelle et puis ils se tapent dessus
comme enfin c'est en fait étranglée en
fait pour vous la peur de violences
conjugales ce qu'on voit là les
vérifiant la cause deux rames pour vous
ce que vous dites c'est que pour tous
les deux c'était un premier amour et qui
n'avaient pas d'expérience amoureux dans
faite d'expériences de relations
sentimentales c'est ça c'est une grande
partie de ce drame et c'est que à un
moment ils n'ont ni l'un ni l'autre la
réflexion ne se pose est de se dire
qu'est ce que je veux mais est-ce que je
suis heureux est-ce que je suis heureuse
est ce que c'est vraiment l'homme qui me
convient ou la femme qui me convient
parce qu'il ya aussi cinq je pense que
ceci le poids notamment la famille
d'alexia elle le dit
derrière ce ce jeune homme est cette
jeune femme il y a des beaux parents qui
sont persuadés qu'ils sont le bonheur
parfait et quand ils le disent un moment
alex air de quitter manhattan pour un
accès un boulanger ou un pâtissier peu
importe il ya un conseil de famille où
on expliqué alexia que c'est hors de
question qu enfin qu'elle est très
heureuse avec johnatan et qu'elle va pas
remettre en cause toute sa vie pour une
amourette ça je trouve que cette
ingérence dans la vie amoureuse comme le
fait d'avoir vécu chez les beaux parents
pour le couple a quelque chose qui a pu
être fatal on va dire dans dans l'issue
amoureuse ce n'est pas ça qui a provoqué
bien évidemment la mort d'alexis un joli
que ce sont des paramètres qui font que
à un moment on peut regretter et je
pense que le livre alors pas le nôtre
mais le livre d'aller de départ en
d'alexia c'est exorciser un peu c'est
une sorte de thérapie moi je le vois
comme ça et la série je l'espère en
reparler bientôt avec martin est ce
qu'au delà de ça je pense qu'elle
appartient à tout le monde et c'est
aussi un enseignement et c'est aussi une
thérapie et ça peut aussi être une
thérapie pour les fans on va voir qui va
jouer votre rôle d'ailleurs dans la
série c'est votre pc votre plus grande
affaire sa plus grosse affaire que vous
ayez à traiter pas dû la faire à plus
médiatiques non la sphère la plus
médiatisée c'est ça c'est de très loin
la plus grosse affaire qu'on est très
c'est ça qu'il faut s est vraiment c'est
la plus médiatique mais pas la sphère la
plus que jamais je n'aurais pensé être
un jour sur votre plateau pour parler de
la sphère de djanet end à vannes je vous
le dis sincèrement